this is beach party they accidentally
destroy a pizza shop so they have him
over for beach party and they save the
day and now they're back in the piece of
shop and there was a literal Blowfish
yeah actually does blow people it yeah
do with it what you will
I was gonna go there I'm good night okay
I'm just wondering how delicious he is
cuz apparently that's a delicacy in
Japan hmm so you dig the Japanese watch
this and just cried a little inside
knowing there was a Blowfish that big
and they just blew it up into
smithereens unlikely um I'm just gonna
say no cuz I don't think they get this
minute Pam
well I really was none left to talk
about this episode no no I was about it
um actually that's kinda hard to think
about what to talk about I I won't say
every single time I think by far my
favorites garnet because I'm just
thinking when she was smashed into a
pizza place and she just wasn't moving
and she was just her staring off and
then they're like garnet come on and
she's suddenly she moves that they well
and I love the I love the ending because
I mean in the first place like we have
been bound from the spirit supplies now
like what what is is it and so they get
unbanned and like her reply of just oh
okay thanks whatever like it reminds me
of some things on the internet a BIA
I can't leave any specifics at the
moment but some people oh my god did you
know this and then this and that oh okay
did you know that they're remaking drop
dead Fred oh no if anything right
Buster's gonna be all chicks what do you
think of that Thor you know I mean it's
just one of those days or it's like I
guess I should ever do it I don't feel
bad not having a big reaction is oh
that's not a good thing there's just
more important stuff but they at the
same time here it's like it is a guys
pizza place but at the same time it's
like they do keep saving the day he says
even gonna miss assistant but they are
constantly saving the day um
but yeah it is might just those
differently I love the bit where the
father keeps sabotaging the game by
threatening his daughter like yeah we
grounded for a month and she moves away
from the ball everybody here is grounded
oh no I thought that was
everybody oh yeah I mean maybe it's cuz
we're we're now at the end of this it's
always like the last one cause you ask
well why don't we just run out of yeah
energy or something and it's just like I
don't know what to say about this one
just it was good it was fun to watch
yeah it was it was fine it was funny it
had some good laughs I like that family
I like the fact that waffle was the girl
that was part of the friends yeah that
they're trying to impress earlier um and
I yeah I guess no connection to the gems
as far as I can see although she looked
the least like that she had a little bit
and at this clip maybe but yeah she
looked bright at least like them um so
yeah I guess I guess there's no
connection uh to try to think what else
that old lady was pretty cool um and
yeah I do kind of like the fact that
like when the game together it isn't
just the family or the father's a stick
in the mud and like they're just not
getting along it's kind of like either
although to cheaters yeah it's like
sometimes they get along sometimes they
don't it kind of works more like a real
good team well um and that that Blowfish
again does work very much like a game
especially when it's looking downward on
the road at all I like how they all
gathering around like in all shouted
orders and I like you to be a bit where
they turn the sand in the glass I
actually did know that like before the
she even explained to them like oh turn
the sand in the glass look at you mr.
wizard
well if fan gets struck by lightning it
leaves these like remains that are
actually like laughs and you know what
you couldn't even say amethyst shall
shut the up ha joke's on you I
still can't um but no I'm fit I'm fit
I'm a tiny Lima I'm a cyst
I must assist yes you are but that's the
second point um no it was fine it was a
fun episode I had some laughs and a good
message and everything um yeah
like I said every time I see it I'm
always reminded how cool guarded its
she's like just always in our own world
always doesn't give a crap but she's not
mean you know she's hairy just like you
know just bear with amethyst as your
properties as well the ability to change
hold on all ever
andum was pretty helpful no I know not I
think I can all agree being able to
change into a ball at random is kind of
awesome indeed
um I mean there's nothing wrong with a
even they're all good characters but
yeah the spray the one that's just every
time I see her I'm like she's she's
gotta figure it out like it's gonna be
okay
garnets on it um but uh she knows what's
going on yeah yeah Andy the accents
awesome you know is something this is at
you too but you know no this is episode
before no this is the episode before I'm
sorry to bring us up here but we're just
running out of stuff to say we shut the
up mm okay um when again just shows
the benefit of getting really good
actors and know what a difference they
can make because when uh when Connie
lands and she has to say the line that
was so cool and it's like what a nothing
like but just they're all there they
just like you know are you okay
that was so cool I mean it's just it
suddenly makes it funny and I love
actors I can take a line where on paper
there's just nothing to it but when they
say it a certain way it's suddenly it's
only interesting in their cartoons and
movies where you could tell it's just a
read and nothing more just emotionless
um I won't name names but they're out
there and I'm trying to there was it oh
I know that commercial you showed me
with Adam West and uh oh I'm back here
all day ready yeah and and you could
tell that he was so not into that this
is just a commercial for him it he's
like quick untie us before it's too late
don't joke around Batgirl why would you
talk about this you know it just was so
typing back to here say if you want oh
it's hilarious it's it's a good
attention but it's it's really awkward
it really funny oh it's another great in
thing of like good intention
ridiculousness yeah um don't joke around
Batgirl huh you don't deserve equal pay
less than women you can baby funny thing
is like it's just so weird because I'm
like man you could make this commercial
today yeah yeah ain't nothing really
changed much well such as that but I'm
like you know Adam West is still doing
his
goofy stick I like their also climate
again I don't yeah I don't know Bert
word could stuff into that that'd be
like a really good commentary like bring
them all back and like to show how
nothing is how it's like still bullcrap
in that department
oh yeah no so it's but that that just
reminded me of like and I've seen that
before in some other commercials where
it's like a celebrity or something doing
a pitch and you could tell those or
those days where they didn't give a
so but in this case yeah a great voice
actor makes all the difference because
you can take seemingly simple lines and
in imbue it with emotion indeed it so
out so there that probably about the
time span do you need it I we just don't
love that much for this one all right
how long is this one two minutes
oh god um I'm doing my fifties dance
thing the Charleston because that's what
they used to do in old cartoon don't
joke around Batgirl equal pay is not
something we should talk about oh yeah
sure